Joe Rogan got quite a bit of heat
recently about mentioning a a paper and
a broader idea which I didn't I don't
think is that controversial but maybe we
can expand on it and the idea is that
vaccines
creates selective pressure
for a virus to mutate
and for variance to form
what uh
first of all from a biological
perspective can you explain this process
and from uh societal perspective what
are we supposed to do about that so
let's get the terminology right so as we
talked about earlier viruses are always
mutating so no vaccine or no drug makes
a virus mutate what that's the wrong
perspective on what you look at it what
the what the immune responses is putting
pressure selection pressure on the virus
and if there's a
one particle with the right mutation
that can escape the antibody that will
emerge right
so that's what happens with influenza
virus right we vaccinate every year
and there are not a lot of people that
get infected so they get natural
immunity
and then the virus is incredibly
varied it mutates like crazy and there's
in some person somewhere there's one
variant that escapes the antibody which
has been induced either by infection or
vaccination it can be both
and that drives the emergence of the new
variants of the next year we need to
change the vaccine
so I would say both natural infection
and vaccination sure select for variance
absolutely there's no question because
they're inducing immunity now what
happened last year was at the beginning
of 2020 very few people in the world
were immune as the virus first started
spreading
but you can see in the sequences of
those isolates from the beginning of
2020. you can see all of the changes
that are now present in the variants of
concerned at very very low frequencies
they were already there but there was no
selection for them to emerge until
November when we now had many millions
of people who had
mostly been infected but also some
vaccinated then we saw the alpha variant
emerge in England probably because of
immune selection now the the virus that
had the change that evaded the antibody
had an advantage
and that virus drove through the
population so that's what we're seeing
we're seeing all these variants are
simply antigenic selections so the
variance the mutations that are at the
core of these quote-unquote variants
they were always there all along the
vaccine
or the infections did not create them
there's no creative but they're selected
it's like the vaccine wipe out
a lot of the variants
right and then
um by being by making your body immune
to them and so but some of them survive
yeah and exactly and there's another
tree that's built and it's unclear what
that tree leads to
I mean it could make things much worse
or much better I would don't we don't
know but with flu we see year after year
the virus changes we change the vaccine
we deal with it we change it again
there's an unending but see that's a
very different story if do you think do
you think kovid will be
um with some likelihood uh like the flu
whereas basically variants will never be
able to
um
eradicate it
will never eradicate it in any case ever
well
come up with a vaccine that uh makes you
immune to enough variants to where
there's not enough evolutionary like
room well if you cut down the number of
infections then you reduce the diversity
sure yes right the problem is if let's
say you're a cynic and you say well
vaccination is just selecting for
variance so let's stop it but then
you're going to have infection and
that's going to select for variance and
there the more you're more likely to get
very sick because we know the vaccines
are really good at preventing you from
dying so that's why it still makes sense
to use vaccines because they prevent you
from dying yeah that's the bottom line
but can we ever make
a vaccine that deals with all variants
absolutely and the reason I say that is
because
people who get
naturally infected with saroskovic they
develop covid they recover
if you if you give them one vaccine dose
they make an immune response that
handles all the variants that are around
right now all of them much better than
people who've gotten two doses of
vaccine for some reason their immune
response is suddenly broadened After The
Infection vaccination and they can
handle all the variants that we know of
so far so that tells me we can
devise a strategy to do the same thing
with a vaccine that makes a really broad
vaccine that'll handle all the very well
you actually uh on the virology blog I
don't know if you're the author of that
but I am I am yes oh the blog yes but
there's a particular post that's talking
about reporting in a paper there's a mix
and match oh yes that's one of my
co-writers uh Trudy Ray yeah yeah that's
a that's an interesting idea that
there's some uh or early evidence now
that uh mixing and matching vaccines
like one shot of Pfizer and one of like
modern or something that creates a much
better
uh immunity than does two shots of
Pfizer I think that's worth exploring
absolutely and this is relevant what
we're doing with influenza
you know instead of having to vaccinate
people every year why can't we devise a
vaccine which you'd get once in your
lifetime or maybe once every 10 years
okay
so the the spike of influenza it's a
long
protein kind of like the spike of SARS
cov2 it's stuck in the virus membrane
and the very tip
that's the part that changes
every year this is where the antibodies
bind
but the stem doesn't change
and if you make antibodies to the stem
they can also prevent infection it's
just that when people are infected or
with the current vaccines it'll make
many antibodies to that stem part but
we're trying to figure out how to make
those and we think they would be broadly
protective and you'd never be able to or
more rarely be able to have a variant
emerge that that escaped it and I think
we can do the same thing with with
coronavirus too for sure